50 years ago he placed his first wreath
through the decades always one step
behind his mother this year he'll step
up as Monarch and head of the Armed
Forces
Alistair Graham supported him as his
Equity between 2002 and 2004 with
Britain caught up in the Gulf War the
now King's dedication to the military
was clear
we were tasked to rearrange the program
to make sure that his majesty could give
as much time as possible to the
regiments uh families that were left
behind while they were serving the next
realm of regiments going out to replace
those that had been part of initial
Invasion and maintaining very close
links through the Chiefs of Staff to
understand what was going on and how the
how the war was progressing and I think
it's it's an intrinsic part of his role
as king and he understands that there is
an indelible link to our Armed Forces
those who know him well say his
understanding developed Early Learning
to Fly with the RAF training with the
parachute regiment and serving as a
captain in the Navy making him some
would say the most military trained King
we've ever had
since 2017 another Duty has been placed
on him laying the Queen's wreath as she
watched on
it was deeply symbolic that the queen
during her lifetime was able to hand
over that important responsibility to
her son and while yes this weekend will
be the first time that he places that
wreath as Monarch the familiarity of
that site means it won't entirely be a
distraction from those they're here to
remember
nearly 10 000 people will join the Royal
British Legion March past 400 veterans
from the Falklands War forming the
largest contingent 40 years since the
war among them Andrew Lawless who says
the king's presence will be welcomed
as he said himself he wants to fall in
his mother's footsteps so his his sense
of due to his sense of service is is
definitely there we know that there's a
solemn part too as well you know it's
not like when I'm marching past the
center top will be you know the names
will be going by through my head off the
of friends and colleagues that are not
here
this weekend the queen will also be
remembered the king led his family and
the country in mourning her death now he
must lead the nation as we all pay
tribute to others who've served Rihanna
Mills Sky News in central London